Since we're going to be doing a lot of math together in this course, a great
place to start would be by talking about numbers, since we'll use them all the
time. What is a number really? Well, it's not a thing out here in the world that
we can see and touch. I at least have never seen a three or a negative 15 and a
half walking around anywhere. Instead, numbers are abstract and we use them as
tools to talk about things that we find around us. A kindergarten teacher, for
example, needs to make sure that none of her students gets lost when she takes
them on a trip to the zoo. One way she could do this would be by constantly
looking at a list of their names and double-checking that every child on the
list is in the group, but this would get really tiring and probably wouldn't be
all that effective. What do you think might be a better way of doing this? Our
first quiz of the course will be a really kind of silly question, but, let's go
with it. How could a teacher make sure that none of her students get lost at the
zoo? And here are a couple of answers that you get to choose from. Tell them all
to be responsible for themselves and not run off. Your second choice is hope for
the best. Your third choice is count them. Your last choice is they probably
shouldn't go on the trip at, at all, just to be safe. Please click the circle
next the choice below, that you think is the best answer. When you've picked
which one you think is right, press the Submit button underneath.